Newport is no stranger to hard times but
with interest rates soaring they're
about to get harder places like this
where incomes are already stretched will
be amongst the worst affected
this local mortgage broker is already
seeing signs of distress so we do think
in the next six to eight months that the
number of calls from potentially
distressed customers is going to
increase mainly due to the fact that
there's 1.4 million people who are
currently on fixed rate deals which may
be historic under two percent deals
coming out onto potentially six percent
or higher
economists predict that 1.2 million
people will go bust this year as a
direct result of higher mortgage
payments the biggest impacts will be
felt here in Wales and also in the
northeast of England but right across
the country people will be pushed to the
brink people like Benjamin who despite a
decent household income will still
struggle
so our current amount is 1 400 a month
and that'll be going up to 2 500 a month
so 1 100 extra obviously our electric
bills have gone up a couple of hundred
quid our Foods customers 30 40 more a
week
um you know we just don't have that sort
of money spare every month so basically
stuck you know can't sell the house to
get rid of the mortgage can't pay the
mortgage amount so I don't know what
we're going to do in a month's time when
it comes to the end of the existing
thing are you doing enough to help
people who are struggling today after a
meeting with the chancellor Banks agreed
to provide more support people who are
at risk of losing their home in that
extreme situation uh the banks and
mortgage lenders have a number of things
in place it's the last thing that they
want to do to repossess a home but in
that extreme situation they've agreed
there will be a minimum 12 month period
before there's a repossession without
consent labor unsurprisingly is Keen to
point the finger at the government
to be many many mortgage holders many
many families across the country who are
now even more worried about paying their
mortgage that's on top of all the other
bills and they know that the
government's failed now for 13 years
they know the government crashed the
economy last year the measures announced
today will help for now but fears remain
that the relief they provide will be
temporary with little sign of interest
rates falling anytime soon
Matthew Thompson Sky News Newport